the simple answer is you know I I
believe in the scientific method I
believe in developing theories and when
I first articulated the concept of the
Golden Circle and start with why it was
a theory
and I set out to test it with looking
for opportunities for it to fail I tried
it in government I tried it in a big
business small business B2B b2c I tried
every place I could go wanting it to
fail so I could improve upon it and so I
love it when there's chaos and things
because I get to test
um and if I were to go back and rewrite
the book I might change a couple of the
case studies because they're just a
little dated I change a little bit of
the language because it's a little dated
but uh but fundamentally I can say with
great pride that that the theory the
theory holds up and it continues to
serve me personally I continue to to
start with wine and lead with why to
this very day